A lot of the discussion around commander
deckbuilding often revolves around the commander,
and this makes sense—it’s right there
in the name of the format. In specific,
how to best utilize your command
zone is a big area of discussion,
and certainly one that I’ve dabbled in plenty.
It’s good when you can get more out of a card
in your deck that you’ll always have access to.
However, there’s a specific deckbuilding choice
I’ve noticed that results from this goal, and
it’s one that kind of bothers me. That choice is
when a player chooses to take their lovely synergy
engine commander and turn it into a combo piece.
Before I go any further, I should make it
clear what I’m not talking about. I’m not
talking about a player building a combo deck where
the commander is one of the combo pieces. No, if
that combo is the deck’s primary gameplan, that’s
actually a great way to build a deck—utilizing the
commander in a combo generally makes that combo
more compact, which gives additional deck space
for interaction, support cards, and alternative
gameplans. My two best decks involve the commander
being used in a combo for this exact reason, and
I’d recommend that to anybody who’s looking for
a powerful starting point for a combo deck.
What I’m talking about here is a deck where
the primary gameplan is something other than
a combo that is focused around the commander,
and a combo that involves the commander is
tossed in as an addition to that. On the surface,
this doesn’t seem like a bad idea—you’ve
already got part of the combo right there,
and having that combo might be decent as an
alternate wincon. This logic works so long as
the combo isn’t significantly better than the
primary gameplan, and especially if the combo
pieces also fit into that plan. If I’m building a
Samut beatdown deck, Combat Celebrant and Sword of
Hearth and Home are both great cards for the deck
in general, and the fact that they also combo with
the haste the commander provides is just an added
bonus that can allow for explosive wins on certain
boardstates. Where things become a problem is when
the combo in question is one that is out of place
and far more powerful than the deck’s normal
gameplan, and this is for a couple reasons.
The first is one I’ve talked about and alluded
to before, and this is the lesser of the two
issues in my view—the vibes issue. If you build
a deck that’s mainly doing one thing but has some
other much more powerful thing it can draw
into 10-20% of the time, that’s gonna lead
to some table whiplash. People come into games
with expectations of how their opponents’ decks
are going to function, and this is fundamental
to any deckbuilding game that requires skill.
Those expectations rely on decks following some
sort of logic, and when a deck does a mixture
of relatively weak things and wildly powerful
things with no rhyme or reason, it’s much more
difficult for people playing against that deck
to conceptualize it and strategize around it.
If you’re looking for a luck-based game
with fantasy aesthetics this might be a
workable situation for you, but on some level it
represents a breakdown of how multiplayer strategy
games work which a lot of players might not find
enjoyable. This reason actually applies to any
situation where stronger and weaker plays coexist,
regardless of whether the commander is involved.
The other issue with making your commander
a combo piece is the much more tangible one,
and that’s that what you do with your commander
will inform how your opponents react to that
commander. When I’m playing against a Zaxara deck
and I have a spare moment to cast a removal spell,
the commander is generally going to be a
medium-value removal target. Certainly, the ramp
it gives is useful, and the X spell ability can
be quite good if the Zaxara player has the right
set up to utilize it, but there will still be lots
of times where I’m mostly comfortable with Zaxara
sticking around for a bit. However, according to
EDHRec, 46% of Zaxara decks run Freed from the
Real, a card that can produce infinite mana with
Zaxara’s ramp ability. And that’s infinite colored
mana in an X-spells deck, so the game will often
end right then and there when that happens. If
I know my opponent is among those 46% and I don’t
wanna hold up mana to remove it later, that Zaxara
immediately becomes a top priority for removal.
If I remove it and they had Freed from the Real
in hand, that’s just good defensive play, but the
other 85% of the time the player probably just had
some hydras and ramp in hand and has experienced
an entirely unnecessary setback in their goofy
midrange deck just because they decided to make
their commander part of an infinite combo. This
sucks for everybody involved—the hydra player gets
their totally fair-magic gameplan slowed down,
and a different player might get to keep
a threatening value engine and pull ahead.
As another example, let’s talk about Tivit, Seller
of Secrets. Now, Tivit is a bit different from
Zaxara in that its combo plan is often the
primary plan. While I’d estimate the number
of Real-Freed Zaxara players who would consider
their deck a genuine combo deck is pretty low,
Tivit’s one card infinite combo with Time Sieve
is the first thing a lot of people think of when
they think about the commander. And indeed, we see
72% of players are running this combo. However,
if we dig a bit deeper, we can also see that
about 45% of players are playing a Tivit
deck that is based around voting. Sorting
by inclusion of Brago’s Representative,
we can see that people building this sort of
deck are running lots of voting-oriented cards,
as well some flicker and artifact synergies—seems
like a pretty reasonable mid-power deck. Let’s
say it’s turn 5 or 6 and this sort of
Tivit player is casting their commander,
and let’s also say I’m holding up a counterspell.
Well, Tivit is certainly a bit concerning—the card
is a strong engine, and him sticking around to
get multiple triggers could lead to the Tivit
player pulling ahead. However, there are plenty
of cases where I’d be fine with Tivit resolving,
especially if there are more opposing turns before
mine. What if another opponent is pulling ahead
and I want a chance at nailing a critical spell
of theirs? What if I have a big board I want to
protect from potential board wipes? What if I’m
holding up a board wipe and have the ability
to clear out the Tivit later with counterspell
backup anyway? In those cases, I might just let
the player have their Tivit and get a bit of mana
and card advantage. But wait, I forgot to mention,
63% of voting-oriented Tivit decks run Time Sieve.
Statistically speaking, no shot that’s resolving,
get your one-card infinite combo deck out of
here, nerd. Once again, this Tivit player could
just be looking to do fun voting things and have
a grand experiment in mildly-rigged democracy,
but unfortunately for them, they decided that
grand experiment in democracy also needed a
one-card infinite combo. So, no, I think
I’ll pass on that one, thank you very much.
This principle is most pronounced with infinite
combos, but it also applies to other scenarios
where a card radically changes the nature of
what a commander does. Take Atraxa—you can do
all sorts of things with the commander, pumping up
+1/+1 counters, loyalty counters, charge counters,
storage counters, and more, and all of these
can work alongside each other just fine. Well,
all except for one. The second you throw
some poison counters on your opponents,
the commander immediately reads “each turn I get
a poison counter” for all of your opponents, and
their removal choices will reflect that. Oh, you
were hoping to do some funny superfriends things
with Atraxa now? No you’re not. Even worse, since
poison counters are almost impossible to remove,
there’s a certain terrifying inevitably that’s
present. Even if Atraxa isn’t in play currently,
the fact that she could be in the future will
likely serve as enough of a threat to warrant
some very focused rounds of attacks. To fully
put on my social theorizing hat, a big part of
casual EDH is figuring out ways to win that your
opponents will allow you to perform the setup
for. Examples of this might consist of getting a
large land count before casting a massive spell,
getting a board of tokens before playing an
overrun effect, setting up some synergy pieces
before landing a centerpiece card that will allow
the deck to surge out of control, and so on. By
contrast, poison counter proliferation is about as
visible and visceral as setup gets—your opponents
will be kicking and screaming against the lurching
inevitability of your gameplan, even when it’s no
stronger on paper than doing a good old fashioned
tokens + overrun. That’s not to say that poison
counters are never a valid win plan, but you
need to know what you’re getting yourself into.
At the end of the day, that’s the main thing
that all of this really comes down to—knowing
what kind of Magic you want to be playing. If your
commander is serving one purpose for your deck,
stretching it to fill more roles can be a great
way to up your overall efficiency and consistency,
but you do need to keep an eye on what
exactly those roles are and whether they
pose dramatically different threats to your
opponents. In my Radha deck, the commander
serves two primary roles—being a mana dork,
and enabling a couple of powerful lieutenant
creatures. This works well because neither of
these purposes step on each other’s toes—removing
the commander early to cut me on mana isn’t a
setback to the lieutenant creatures because I
haven’t played any yet, and removing the commander
as a lieutenant enabler isn’t a major setback to
mana generation because having Radha as a mana
dork isn’t that important past turn 4 anyway.
It also is possible to have your commander
perform roles that conflict in some way,
and having that work out just comes back to,
once again, knowing what kind of Magic you want
to play. In my strongest deck, Malcolm is both
a combo piece and a mana engine. This frequently
renders him the scariest creature on board,
and also means that him eating a removal spell
is a pretty major setback. I account for this by
running a massive pile of counterspells that I can
cast using the treasures Malcolm generates—I know
exactly how my opponents are going to be feeling,
and I’m prepared to say no if they send their
removal spells in the most logical direction.
I also made the deck as consistent as possible at
getting Time Sieve out, because my opponents are
going to be bracing for it anyway in how they
treat Malcolm, so I may as well make sure the
effort I spend defending Malcolm isn’t in service
of janky pirate beatdown. When it comes down to
it, I’m not trying to give any hard and fast
rules here, I’m just trying to make sure that
players have their expectations well-calibrated.
If you’re prepared to fight ruthlessly to keep
your commander in play, that’s great and I
wish you all the luck in the world in that
battle. On the contrary, if you’re just here for
a good time and don’t want to fight that battle,
don’t build your deck in a way that gives
other people extra reasons to kill your stuff.